SCP-999, also known as The Tickle Monster.
It’s one of the most adorable, beloved,
and undeniably wholesome anomalies ever to
exist in the SCP Foundation’s containment
facilities.
Its mere presence can cause joy and comfort,
cure depression and other mental illnesses,
and even sometimes cause violent and unpredictable
creatures to really mellow out.
If you’re a fan of this channel, chances
are that you’re a big fan of SCP-999, too.
But that doesn’t mean everyone is on board:
As we all know, there are plenty of entities
and groups in the SCP Universe that are downright
evil, and as a result, would love to see this
little blob of pure joy crushed to a pulp
or sacrificed to a cosmic horror.
But you can’t ever underestimate -
wait a second.
Is that the Containment Breach alarm?
All Foundation staff members report to the
affected cell immediately!
It looks like an SCP has escaped containment
and is now… in our world?
That’s right, SCP-999 has broken out of
SCP Foundation control and now you can finally
have a Tickle Monster of your very own!
In plush form!
This super adorable plush from SCP Swag is
11 inches of huggable, squeezable, joy and
now that the Tickle Monster is out of containment,
you can bring it into your own home.
Tickle Monster Plushes are available for pre-order
now, and all orders made in the next ten days
also get a special limited First Edition Card!
Worldwide shipping is available, so go to
SCP Swag dot com right now and pre order your
own Tickle Monster!
And let us know in the comments what SCP anomalies
you want to see in plush form next!
But as we were saying - you can’t ever underestimate
SCP-999: Not only has it tickled SCP-682 into
submission, there are also certain theories
floating around the foundation that it will
one day grow so powerful, its forces of pure
goodness and joy can overthrow the Scarlet
King himself.
That’s why today we’re throwing the Tickle
Monster into a kind of Royal Rumble with all
the baddest dudes the Foundation has ever
encountered, and we’re going to give our
theories on how SCP-999 might somehow find
the good in even the blackest of hearts.
First, SCP-096 - The Shy Guy, a killing machine
so brutal, direct, and opaque in its motives
that some have even questioned whether it
actually has sentience.
However, we’d personally stake our claim
that it does.
When a photo of this savage beast was taken
with SCP-978, the Desire Camera - a camera
that shows the deepest desires of its subjects
- it revealed that the Shy Guy secretly just
had the desire to disappear.
Not only does this suggest that the monster
may not actually like killing people, but
the very idea that it can have a desire also
implies some level of intelligence.
But how would SCP-999 enter the mix?
Well, we know that 096 is an anxious creature.
It spends the majority of its time just pacing
its cell, and when someone sees its face,
it begins sobbing uncontrollably before entering
its rage state.
Does this sound like a happy entity to you?
If the Shy Guy encountered 999 at its full
joy-giving power, we personally think that
it might finally chill out a little.
Perhaps it’d take a moment to breathe and
contemplate life a little more.
Maybe it’d wonder why it’s so ashamed
of its face, and feels the need to hunt down
and kill anyone who sees it.
After all, there are much uglier anomalies.
Like SCP-106!
He’s the next monster to join this weird,
wild cage match against SCP-999.
While 096 is violent, 106 is downright malevolent
- he’s not just sentient, but extremely
intelligent.
The Old Man loves causing pain and suffering
for his own perverse pleasure, just as much
as heavy-hitters like 682.
So surely 999 would have its work cut out
for it here?
Well, not necessarily.
There are two leading theories about who 106
actually is.
One being the Scranton theory and the other,
the Corporal Lawrence theory.
The first dictates that 106 is the result
of Dr. Robert Scranton, physically and mentally
transformed by his time in SCP-3001, the terrifying
Red Reality.
The second theory was that he was a World
War One soldier known as Corporal Lawrence,
whose anomalous encounter in the trenches
turned him into the beast he is today.
In either case, he’s a man shaped by pain
and anomalous trauma - much like 096, the
Desire Camera revealed an insight into 106’s
mind: His greatest desire consists of him
walking across a field towards an old house,
where an old woman smiles and waits for him.
Many believe this old woman to be his estranged
wife.
Perhaps an encounter with SCP-999 would cause
106’s sadism to abate, reminding him of
the humanity he once had.
Maybe he’d become a kindly old man in the
aftermath - who prefers Werther’s Originals
to violence and spinning long, rambling yarns
about the war rather than chasing people around
his terrifying pocket dimension.
It’s a thought so sweet it could almost
make you sick.
Thankfully, one of our favorite doctors is
next on the list - specifically, the Plague
Doctor, SCP-049.
While he definitely isn’t as dangerous or
malicious as either of his predecessors, 049
has racked up quite a body count in his hundreds
of years of operations.
He sees Pestilence everywhere he goes, except
within, and can kill with a mere touch.
However, his deadly touch only seems to apply
to non-anomalous animals and humans, not other
anomalies, so he definitely couldn’t harm
999, and The Tickle Monster, conversely, could
definitely touch him back.
While the Plague Doctor is the serious type,
he might not be able to keep his bedside manner
after a serious tickling.
And we’d be more than willing to hedge our
bets on him having the laugh of an angel.
While 049 may have folded in the face of 999’s
tickling wrath, our next contestant is as
solid as a rock.
Well, technically as solid as concrete.
That’s because it’s SCP-173, also known
as the Sculpture or The Peanut.
It shows no emotions, and murders anything
that blinks in its presence by snapping its
neck.
But 999 doesn’t even have bones, let alone
a neck, so SCP-173 has nothing with which
to threaten this happy little blob.
And what about SCP-999’s counter-offensive?
If the Tickle Monster got its slime all over
SCP-173, it might finally reform this statuesque
serial killer through prolonged exposure.
Maybe after that 173 will give relaxing neck
massages rather than snapping them.
But while the Sculpture may be intimidating,
it’s nothing compared to an unkillable,
mass-murdering blademaster, right?
Of course, we’re talking about SCP-076,
also known as Able.
No matter how many times he gets put down,
he keeps coming back, with unparalleled skills
in physical combat and the ability to pull
huge blades out of thin air.
He also appears to be fueled by pure, unstoppable
rage.
So how on earth could our adorable tickle
monster possibly go toe to toe with a swordsman
who cuts through elite Mobile Task Force soldiers
like a hot knife through a D-Class?
Much like SCP-106, it seems like a lot of
Able’s rage is rooted in a deep pain caused
by his past.
If he truly is the biblical Abel, it’s likely
that his rage stems from being the very first
murder victim, betrayed and killed by his
brother, Cain - now known as SCP-073.
Spending time with SCP-999 might finally calm
him down enough to actually work through some
of these issues and come to a sense of closure.
Maybe, with SCP-999 at his side, Able could
attend some therapy sessions with Foundation
psychologists until he finally felt as though
he’d moved past his murderous urges - perhaps
even working up to family counseling with
Cain.
He could then re-enter society, and reapply
his expert knife skills and become a Bobby
Flay-style celebrity chef - except one who
could actually flay you if you got on his
bad side.
But let’s talk about an SCP that’s frankly
dangerous to even discuss.
I am of course referring to SCP-2521.
Oh great, I’m not dead.
Wonderful.
Let’s carry on.
2521 is attracted to any information about
it, written or spoken.
It will immediately appear upon the creation
of this information and steal either the information
itself or the person disseminating it in the
case of verbal words.
If someone were to pass SCP-999 a fact sheet
on SCP-2521, it would inevitably manifest
and prepare to throw down.
But perhaps the positive influence of SCP-999
would change SCP-2521’s tune.
Rather than obsessively stealing information
about itself, the being may instead finally
open up and speak about itself.
We might even learn some interesting things,
like the fact that it used to have a bowling
team with SCP-106 and SCP-049.
He also loves knitting-
Oh, come on, not again!
Now, how about we go for something a little
closer to human: SCP-082, Fernand the Cannibal,
a huge, ogre-like humanoid that has a penchant
for pathological lies and also devouring human
heads.
And, well, the rest of the body too, if he’s
worked up enough of an appetite.
He’s super strong and has a hide so thick
that seemingly no weapon can penetrate it.
How could SCP-999 possibly go a round with
a behemoth like this?
Lucky for 999, Fernand has an extremely cheerful
temperament.
If a potential victim can keep him amused,
often listening and playing along with his
elaborate fantasies, it massively increases
their chance of survival.
And considering SCP-999 is literally a good
vibes machine, there’s a good chance that
it’d keep Fernand so amused that the thought
of getting hangry wouldn’t even cross his
mind.
Once again, little SCP-999 takes home the
W.
But what about a real sadist?
A truly heartless monster whose commitment
to focused, endless cruelty is genuinely unparalleled?
We’re talking about the being from SCP-3999.
This terrifyingly powerful reality warper
hasn’t racked up scores of victims, because
it prefers the quality of suffering over quantity.
It’ll select a single victim, trap them
in their own personal hell, and spend a literal
eternity conceiving every possible torture
and torment to break the spirit and body of
the victim, never giving them the luxury of
death.
However, if any entity could turn the tables
and break the spirit of SCP-3999, it would
be SCP-999.
Picture it: Thousands of years where the monster
tries everything it can to break the Tickle
Monster’s spirit, only to find its own spirit
being broken as 999 doesn’t succumb to any
of it and continues to project love and kindness
throughout.
Could you imagine anything more frustrating
for a creature like 3999?
Eventually, it would probably get so frustrated
that it would let 999 go, and go find some
hapless Foundation researcher to torture instead.
Going up against a single anomalous being,
regardless of its power, is one thing, but
taking on an entire group is another challenge
for SCP-999.
What if 999 became trapped in SCP-3008, the
endless Ikea, surrounded by the deadly Staff
in the middle of the night?
Our theory is that the positive presence of
SCP-999 would really help the nightmarish,
malformed Staff of this accursed Ikea, turn
their lives around and start creating a more
positive work environment around the store.
Rather than trying to chase the survivors
trapped inside the store and beat them to
death, they would instead help them find the
ideal furniture for enhancing their lifestyle
if ever they managed to escape the building.
999 would help them go from horrifying to
helpful in no time.
It’d be so nice in there that the survivors
wouldn’t even want to leave!
But what about groups of interest?
Let’s say the Chaos Insurgency has broken
into a containment site in another one of
its classic raids against the Foundation.
Would a group of elite Chaos Insurgency operatives
be able to take down the Tickle Monster?
We think not.
While these anomaly-stealing militants may
be hardcore compared to your average joe,
they’re nowhere near as hateful or irredeemable
as the likes of 682 or 106.
Chances are if they spent any amount of time
around 999, they’d experience a sudden sense
of mellowness, and begin to rethink all of
their poor life choices.
But what about the GOC?
Those government stooges obsessed with killing
any anomaly they can get their hands on?
Personally, we theorize that a run-in with
SCP-999, and the immensely positive feelings
it causes, would cause them to reevaluate
their entire philosophy on the anomalies they
encounter and lead them to restructure their
entire organization from the ground up.
Perhaps they’d even promote SCP-999 to the
position of Undersecretary-General, and perhaps
even change the meaning of the group’s acronym
to “Givers of Cuddles” in honor of their
new leader and direction.
We can dream, right?
But let’s end this dream with a nightmare:
The Scarlet King, the most dangerous being
in the entire multiverse, who is also strongly
believed to be SCP-999’s real father.
Awkward.
Can ultimate good someday defeat ultimate
evil?
According to ancient Daevite prophecies - a
terrifying historical culture that worshipped
the Scarlet King - yes, it can, if given the
time and nurturing it needs to reach full
power.
How exactly would that battle play out?
Well...it’s difficult to even theorize,
but chances are, it’d be a battle of truly
biblical proportions.
And if ever the Scarlet King did breach our
dimension, it’s safe to say that you’d
want your own little SCP-999 close at hand.
And now you can!
Go to SCP Swag dot come and pre-order a Tickle
Monster plush of your very own!
It doesn’t even need any anomalous powers
to bring you a ridiculous amount of joy.
Orders placed in the next ten days get a special
limited First Edition Card so don’t wait!
Get yours now before they’re all gone!
Now go check out “SCP-999 - The Tickle Monster”
and “Children of SCP-001 The Scarlet King
- Is SCP-999 Really His Son?” for more on
everyone’s favorite little creature!